[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday March 23rd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
picture this you sign in for what
promises to be a busy day at work only
to find out the password for your
company login is about to expire and you
need to make a new one annoying maybe
time consuming depends on how many
places you need to log back into
cyber security risk well researchers say
it could be
and HR and corporate it departments
aren't the only ones that use poor and
ineffective password practices here to
discuss these techniques and why they
pose potential security risks is our
Tech columnist Christopher Mims hi
Christopher thanks for joining us Zoe
always a pleasure to be here alright I'm
sure many listeners have experienced the
requirement that they update their
password or create passwords using what
can feel like arbitrary rules such as
you know using capital letters or
special characters why do researchers
say these could be security risks it
turns out that if you study how people
actually use these systems and behave
when they are given these somewhat
arbitrary rules we are smart but lazy
and we tend to
create the simplest possible password
that satisfies the requirements that
we've been given so for example if
people are being forced to create a new
password every month or every three
months
the thing that people tend to do is come
up with one password and then just put
you know a number on the end and then
just increase that number by one every
time if they're allowed to or if they're
forced to put in a special character
we've all done this to just put an
exclamation point on the end of the
password and that doesn't actually make
the password secure are there other
places that we see this apart from
company logins are there other companies
that Force users to do this a shocking
number of companies have these funny
rules and these are consumer internet
services there's actually this website
called
dumbasswordrules.com if you want to look
it up and also a lot of companies do a
surprising thing where if you put in a
very guessable or insecure password like
if you want to make your password one
two three four five six
you can do that and security researchers
say that we shouldn't be allowed to put
in really guessable passwords or
passwords that are frequently used this
is one of the few arbitrary rules that
that should be enforced something I've
been curious about we're seeing the use
of AI everywhere are we also seeing it
when it comes to hackers trying to get
our passcodes for things one of the
amazing things about hackers guessing
passwords these days is that they are
now able to use these giant lists of
leaked passwords that are all available
on the internet you know from past hacks
there's millions and millions of these
passwords to train AIS to try to guess
what a person's password might be and
because every single one of us has had
passwords leaked in these breaches
hackers can then use that record of
passwords that are associated with our
name or our email address
to try to guess oh you know this person
tends to use their pet's name and then
add some special characters on the end
well let's try some variants on that
and it shrinks the number of passwords
that they have to guess so if these
rules aren't helping to keep sites safe
why do it departments keep using them I
think in some ways companies have become
so frustrated with the insecurity of
passwords that they are moving to what's
called Security in depth where they're
like well probably hackers might break
in so let's have so-called zero trust
security inside of our system where we
assume that any account could be
compromised or let's lean harder on
two-factor Authentication
this is great the problem with all of
these means is that eventually these
other types of security can be bypassed
and what researchers have told me over
and over again is yeah we might be
moving toward a passwordless future but
on our most secure accounts we will
always have multiple secrets that
identify us as who we say we are and so
passwords could be with us for the long
run because all these other means of
identifying ourselves whether they're
Biometrics or two-factor authentication
eventually they're going to become less
secure than they are now as hackers
figure out how to break them
tell me a little bit more about that you
mentioned two-factor authentication you
mentioned passwordless ways to enter our
systems why aren't more companies
adopting those or are they and we're
just not noticing yeah one of the
challenges with these extra layers of
security like passwordless and so-called
two-factor authentication which you may
have experienced if your bank sends you
a code that you got to enter when you're
trying to log in
number one they're less convenient so
people tend to not want to do this to
log into every single one of their
accounts so it's always a minority it's
always 20 or 30 percent of people who
might have these On Any Given account
and the other challenge with these is
that you know it can be tricky to make
it work especially with this newer
standard of passwordless authentication
you know it only works on some devices
it only works on some web browsers and
frankly the world runs on Old systems
old code government runs on that our
infrastructure does so all of those
older systems you know they're going to
be protected by passwords for the
foreseeable future so it sounds like
what you're saying is passwords aren't
going away and researchers say the more
we change them the less secure they may
be so what do they want people to do so
there are a number of good basic
security practices that it departments
could shift to you know a simple one is
encouraging people to use longer
passwords and one way to get people to
do that successfully is don't make them
include a bunch of random special
characters don't make them change that
password very often because if you can
encourage somebody to to create a long
password the first time and just stick
with it that may be the most secure
option also of course people should be
using things like online password
lockers password managers they're called
but you know judging by my inbox there's
a lot of readers who are still not
comfortable with that all right that's
Wall Street Journal Tech columnist
Christopher Mims thanks for joining us
Christopher thanks so much for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing but a quick reminder before we
go we still want to hear your questions
about generative artificial intelligence
AI programs like chat GPT Microsoft's
new Bing or Google's new Bard and we're
going to answer them on an upcoming
episode send us a voice recording to tnb
wsj.com or leave us a voicemail with
your AI question at
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]